hello and welcome to this video playing
Kelly on I'm down one game and against
him I lost them a pretty stupid game
with rook against Luke or something some
sometime play last time 95 it's an
uncommon move here don't know maybe even
this is good right a 3 is the most i
must come and move ok so what now may be
knighted up to d5 possibly to be six
okay a three I don't don't quite get the
idea what is the point of a three yeah
okay I'm just going to open up the
position now not thinking about this too
long really don't want to lose on time
again in some in some non position okay
you just develop here you're probably
takes it six now I counterplay ideas
with would be three in this position and
just bishop t5 if you move the bishop
I'll have c5 so I should have some some
good active counter chances here
ship to f4 okay now you just enter enter
here immediately see that there's some
active active play going on yeah I don't
sigh don't get c5 and at the moment
easily okay
I cannot play Ruby 8 this is quite
annoying
and you don't see a really good move
here in this position
don't see a good move that's kind of
weird I can maybe this one I don't I
don't see something good
yeah i'm giving up the c7 porn but they
can actually take on c7 right I am
Bishop c6 known i have bishop physics
okay so I wonder what what he thinks
about stare some alternative to Bishop
65 it seems unlikely
my idea was haunted this Bishop takes
just move the rook and then play like h5
try to claim compensation in this
position okay as usually place the most
ambitious move Yahoo p7 is kind of lame
cannot go see five unfortunately ok
let's go for this
it can be several s the idea I don't
know no age 3 wants to go queen bee
seven now this is the point ok so rook
e8 does Ruby age ok
okay so quinta five I guess now why
these two ponds up and this is not full
compensation
and try to get something going on the
light squares but it won't be enough
rookie one for example it's not bad
hmm yeah hope you won as I mentioned
that was a decent move cannot activate
the rook here ok the Sibyl plaque when
you form time morning check
now I simply happy now I don't know what
happened to you this game actually okay
I'll tell you I was somehow worse out of
the opening even though that line is
nothing for white I'm not sure what went
wrong check
I'm just continuing him without having
any big sean screech 72 swin yeah of
course ah lack is that i don't know i
played this probably just too too
relaxed thinking that this is bad for
white anyway and i mean it it's probably
not great but it's also not terrible
okay so yeah maybe it's maybe the
catcher is bad I don't know rook be a
duster some more obvious move but I
thought taking and c5 was pretty dynamic
yeah maybe this is better I really
shouldn't have a problem out of the
opening as 95 it's just not a
particularly good move it just takes a
lot of time and leg as a poner I mean
the phone structure is bad but it is
just a pawn probably rupee aid is this
better that's very it's very likely
because this is not not so easy to play
now maybe this was all too quickly
played influenced by the last game I
lost against him on time yes enough
judge just helps white you I don't I
don't have to take open this openness
bishop I can just play but should be 60
on something yeah it was just a very bad
game by black and here I'm starting to
to be in trouble I mean it's kind of
it's kind of annoying already him it's
hard to not lose a pawn and you don't
really get any compensation so yeah I
was so strong here with with each form
maybe this was badass hmm computer is
actually still kind of okay with my
position surprisingly
you know I took and then played this but
Quincy 7 you can just grab everything
because he always has clean v7 to defend
like this and now there is no wait on g2
now oh yeah I'm just kind of yeah I
don't know I have no idea in this
pollution I'm just losing yeah it was a
really bad game especially the opening i
just i mean it's it's always difficult i
have those games where I idiotically
loose on time and then sometimes try to
speed up and play quicker and the
opening and then if you don't have an
opening on the board that you know well
like the groom felt I mean I don't know
well then playing quickly sometimes
leads to exotic erotic decisions like
this this is a one-second move this is
just totally bad and quite obviously bad
if you look at this again why should I
take in the open up his bishop it just
completely it just mindless yeah if you
play something like this I have no
problem whatsoever here as the bishop is
not putting any pressure on my pawns you
know the computer gives something like
this and then we are even Sivan c5 is
playable now even this is playable yes
this is pretty pretty bad yeah there was
a very bad game by me okay thanks for
watching